monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé de
couple j'ai parlé simplement de relation
la construction européenne s'est faite
après guerre grâce à la convergence
d'intérêts entre une Allemagne qui
cherchait la rédemption et une France
qui voulait incarner sa puissance les
temps ont changé l'Allemagne ne s'excuse
plus elle s'affirme et la France est à
sa remorque déjà distancé en matière
économique notre pays risque à présent
le déclassement diplomatique tout ceci
parce que l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne va recentrer géopolitiquement
l'Allemagne au centre de l'Europe
est-elle capable l'Allemagne aujourd'hui
de mieux articuler ses intérêts propres
avec l'intérêt stratégique supérieur que
nos deux pays partagent une Europe de la
paix et de la liberté